we're told that omar's class has 28
students in it 21 of them take the bus
to school
what percentage of the students in
omar's class take the bus to school
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right well i'm going to try to
visualize this with what we call a
dub and a double number line
so let's say that is 0 and 28
is the total number of students in this
classroom right over here
it's a double number line because i'm
going to make another number line right
below it but i'm going to write these
points in terms of percentages
so 0 students would be 0
of the students in omar's class and 28
students would be
100
of the students in omar's class
and so what we really need to do now is
we know that 21 of them take the bus
21 is going to be roughly around here so
that's 21. so we really just need to
figure out is what percentage is this
going to be
one way to think about it is what
fraction is 21 of 28
well if i write 21 over 28
we know that we can divide both the
numerator and the denominator by 7.
they're both divisible by 7 21 divided
by 7
is 3 and 28 divided by 7 is 4.
so 21 is 3 4 of 28. so let's divide this
number line from 0 to 28 into fourths so
that would be halfway and now we have it
divided into fourths and we can see that
21 is one two three of these fourths
well if 21 is three-fourths of the way
to 28 then whatever percentage this is
here that would be three-fourths of the
way to a hundred so let's divide this
into fourths as well
now we know that one-fourth of a hundred
is twenty-five percent two-fourths of a
hundred is fifty percent
three-fourths of a hundred is
seventy-five percent so what percentage
of the students in omar's class take the
bus to school
75 percent